we're following some breaking news here  at this hour a deadly house fire  overnight in henderson hector mejia live  there at the scene near paseo verde and  st rose parkway hector what's the latest  now just a few minutes ago henderson  fire department confirmed a second woman  has died in this fire  happened at a home here in this gated  community again two people dead  according to a spokesperson two women  died firefighters rushed in they pulled  those two women from that burning home  rushed him to the hospital but  unfortunately they did not survive we  are standing by for additional updates  we'll let you know as soon as we learn  more reporting live in henderson hector  mejia live local now